هكذا يتم تدريب المقاتلين الاوكرانيين على
القياده والتحكم في الطائرات المسيره
المصنعه محليا والتي تؤدي مهام قتاليه
واستخباراتيه واحيانا عمليات انقاذ في
جبهات القتال وكلما اتقن الجنود القياده
وتمتعوا بالخبره قل عدد الخسائر البشريه
والماديه للجيش الاوكراني
درسنا لمده اسبوع على جهاز المحاكاه
واسبوع انفصالات الالعاب الرياضيه كل هذا
لا يعتمد على الطائره بدون طيار نفسها بل
على القذيفه التي تحملها واين ستضرب هذه
المقذوفه من الممكن تحيد دبابه بخزان واحد
او بثلاثه هذا مهم جدا طائرات كمكاز
المنتجه محليا والتي اطلق عليها المصنعون
اسم يبوش تزن اقل من كيلو جرام ويمكنها
الطيران بسرعه تصل الى 200 كيلومتر في
الساعه دون اي صوت تقريبا كما تستطيع ان
تحمل ذخيره تصل الى كيلو جرام وقادره على
ضرب الدبابات ومعتمده من وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه
هذه طائره بدون طيار تستخدم مره واحده هنا
يتم تثبيت العبوه المتفجره باي شكل يبتكره
العسكريون مصنوعه من ماده بلاستيد ذات
عناصر مدهشه على شكل معدن وقطع وكره
واسلاك هذه الطائره تعمل بشكل اساسي ضد
المشاه يمكن ان تحمل هذه الطائره بدون
طيار 500 الى 600 جرام
المنتجون الاوكرانيون لديهم الفرصه لتحسين
وتطوير منتجاتهم من المسيرات التي تؤدي
مهام قتاليه او استطلاعيه نسبه لحصولهم
على ردود افعال فوريه من العسكريين على
الجبهات حيث يتبادل معهم المتخصصون
العسكريون المعلومات عن كفاءه المنتج
واحتياجات المعركه ويمثل ذلك اختبارا
حقيقيا للمنتج للوصول لافضل نموذج للطائره
عسكريين وانطباعهم مهم جدا بالنسبه لنا
اذا قال الجيش ان شيئا لم ينجح ويحتاج الى
تحسين فنحن نحاول حل هذه المشكلات جيش
الطائرات بدون طيار هو مشروع مشترك بين
هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ودائره الدوله للاتصالات
ووزاره التحول الرقمي يوفر البرنامج شراء
طائرات بدون طيار بناء على طلب الجيش وقد
تم بالفعل ابرام سته عشر عقدا للمنتجين
المحليين مع الوزراء بالاضافه الى دوره
تدريبيه للطيارين يستفيد منها الجنود
النشطون والمتطوعون الاحتياطيون
العربيه كيف